so i'm like
what do you like oh that's right some
schmoney gang
that's 2 million
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cardi b gives offset 2 million reasons
to smile for his 30th birthday
the i like it rapper gifted her hubby
this 2 million dollar check you heard me
correct two million dollars
oh yes honey on tuesday cardi documented
offset's milestone birthday celebration
on instagram
that's the migos rapper casually
throwing money into the crowd not too
long after that cardi let the crowd
witness her giving offset the very
generous gift so babe this is my
birthday to you i know you got a lot of
business ventures coming in 2022 so
let's get
it again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and here's culture's dad smiling ear to
ear after receiving the big bucks now
this extravagant gift comes at no
surprise because the couple always goes
big when it comes to birthdays when
cardi turned 29 back in october offset
gifted her with multiple lavish presents
including some bling that's her massive
diamond necklace in the shape of a
playboy bunny then offset gave her this
fur coat with her name embroidered on
the side
[Music]
and cardi's final birthday gift from her
hubby a mega mansion in the dominican
republic oh snappity snap snap the bodak
yellow wrapper revealed the stunning six
bedroom seven and a half bathroom house
offset surprised her with on instagram
cardi shared her excitement writing in
part quote this was so amazing to me for
one i'm so happy that you were actually
really listening to me and not just
smiling and nodding your head so i could
stop talking to you about it
some big big things on the way big bangs
now back to offset's big birthday the
mom of two posted a sweet tribute
praising him and shared a cute video of
the rapper with their three-year-old
daughter culture what's talking to you
ah my face is big
as well as this rare glimpse of their
newborn son in the hospital
back in 2018 cardi gushed to e.t about
what offset is like as a dad he already
has three kids so i already fell in love
uh the way that he was a dad already i'm
like oh my god i can have a little one
with this guy he's really good he's
really good
[Music]
you